- Okay, so Team Gary
has made a lot of content over the years,
but what's your favorite piece of content?
That was me.
- That's a great question.
My favorite content by far is--
(air whooshing)
I'm considering doing a
VaynerMedia Operations
Stay at Home Day once a week forever,
because I'm pretty sold that
I've gotten more done per day,
than sometimes in a month.
(air whooshing)
But here's the punchline,
like fucking, like it's
the words out of my mouth,
not the fucking camera quality.
"Good news GaryVee, I bought
the Sony fucking 694,"
I'm like, "I don't give a fuck!
"It's still not gonna make
you interesting, dick!"
(air whooshing)
(clicks)
(thuds)
If you are fortunate enough
to be watching this right now,
and not being somebody
who's lost a loved one because of this,
or who doesn't have
somebody on a ventilator,
no matter how much business you lost,
back to Katee's question
about being an influencer,
your restaurant being closed,
money doesn't mean shit
when somebody you love the
most in the world dies.
And so this is perspective time.
Be grateful for what you have,
don't cry about what's changed.
It's devastating for seniors
that missed out on their
prom and graduation.
I understand that's your world,
but I promise you,
thank God that everybody
in your family is okay.
Focus on the good,
focus on the gratitude,
because if you watch the news all day,
if you go on social all day,
you're getting into fear,
everything's fucked,
da, da, da, da, da,
blah, blah, blah.
Get your fucking mind right.
Make sure corona got your mind right.
(thuds)
If you do not love losing
you lost.
(whirring)
♪ I feel I can't lose ♪
♪ I'm mortal, immortal, immortal ♪
(air whooshing)
(beeping)
- What's up guys,
my name is Dustin,
I'm a videographer for Team GaryVee.
Gary wanted to go live on
Facebook every single morning,
which then became, as you know,
"Tea With GaryVee."
I usually handle a lot of
Gary's livestream stuff,
and his podcast setups,
and stuff like that.
We had to figure out how
to make this work remotely.
I'm gonna teach you how to do
that later in this episode,
but first, watch this clip,
from Monday's episode
of "Tea With GaryVee."
(air whooshing)
- How are you?
- I'm excellent, I'm excellent.
It's pretty amazing, actually,
to be able to be on a call with you,
so I'm pretty excited about that.
- Thank you brother.
What's cooking?
- Well, you saw my question.
I sell restaurant point-of-sale software,
so I help restaurant owners
make their businesses more efficient,
help them run their business,
grow their sales, and so forth.
And with this shutdown, man,
it's just affecting all of them,
and so I'm just curious
as to what ideas you might have for them
to help them through it.
- I mean, for them,
they've gotta re-engineer
their infrastructure
to be able to do local delivery,
or, if they've got the savings to weather
the 125, the 100.
This could be, for
restaurants and public places,
you could be looking at
three-fourths of a year,
because even when we open back up,
I think there's gonna be hesitation.
It's gonna be a little
while for public places
to get all the way back,
because even if we open
up in three months,
I know my mom, and other
people that are scared,
are gonna be a little
less excited about going.
There'll be a whole group
that couldn't wait to go out,
so there'll be that pent up,
but it could be a little while
before it gets to even-steven.
So I think there's two things.
One, they gotta innovate,
and they gotta innovate in two ways.
Either from a branding standpoint,
or from a operational standpoint.
Either, they build out significant
delivery infrastructure,
so it's not only the
ability to have DoorDash,
or Uber Eats,
or seamless pickup from them,
it's also the ability
to have the capabilities
of prepping those meals
and things of that nature.
But it's also building
up awareness in marketing
so that people choose their restaurant
versus a different one.
And number two, I think
they need to make content.
If I owned a restaurant right now,
I'd be in my restaurant, by myself.
If I was a owner-chef,
I would literally make a video
of every single dish we have on the menu.
Tell the world your story.
I think of it right now as this.
I think the coronavirus has caused us all
to be into one huge, virtual
campfire in the fucking 1300s,
so when you could go round and
tell each other our stories,
which is what we used
to do, pre-television,
pre- fucking everything, radio,
we used to sit around
and tell fucking stories
from the fucking heart and from the brain.
And I think every small business right now
needs to tell their story.
Why they started their business,
how they started their business.
War stories, a.k.a., bad
things that have happened,
hero stories, a.k.a.,
great things that happened,
and then go into detail of their business.
I would walk around my fucking restaurant
and be like, "Here's why
we kept these chairs,
"I didn't have any fucking money,
"I bought 'em at a garage sale.
"This sign came from,"
like tell the world your story
in the form of 50 videos.
The end.
I think everybody should do that.
This is about doing over dwelling.
Right now, 98% of people are gonna dwell.
And the 2% that do, and make,
and create, and go on offense,
and realize an opportunity,
will succeed 10X,
and that's the way the game is played.
(upbeat electronic music)
Thank you for everybody
who spent two hours with me this morning.
I'm gonna try to do a bunch
of these this week, next week,
I mean, the more corona,
the more teatime at Gary's,
so, Dustin, thank you,
the rest of the team, thank you.
Everybody who watched this morning,
I wish you guys nothing but the best,
much love (smacks lips), see ya.
(air whooshing)
(dynamic electronic music)
(upbeat rock music)
- [Dustin] Andrew's on now.
- Andrew.
- [Dustin] Just so you know, it's 9:55.
- Thank you.
Yeah, I know I gotta go in five minutes.
Everybody, I gotta cut today short--
- Hello.
- We'll do two hours
tomorrow, again, I think.
Is that right, Dustin?
Is that where--
- Yeah.
- Okay, I gotta go to a
finance meeting for Vayner,
so real life shit,
so let's sneak in one quick,
Andrew, got a question?
- For sure, my man.
So, first of all, thank
you for having me on.
Basically my question was,
if I wanna make a kind of content
that I feel might ostracize me
from the people that are closest to me,
how do I get over that fear?
- Easy.
By realizing that anybody
who'd be ostracized,
or not like you as much,
about you talking about something
that you're passionate and
interested in talking about
is somebody that is not something
that you need to be valuing.
They need to love you--
- Gotcha.
- All of you, all the true of you.
What, are you gonna live a fake life?
You're gonna maintain friends and family
predicated on things that,
like you're literally not
gonna talk about the things
that you wanna talk about in life,
because your best friend,
or your mom, or your uncle,
or younger sister, or your homies,
are gonna think it's weird,
or inappropriate, or?
You don't want those
friendships anyway, I mean that.
And I promise you,
don't underestimate friends and family,
they tend to step up.
(bright music)
All right everybody,
I hope you enjoyed today's
episode of "Tea With GaryVee."
I'm super excited to be doing this show.
(gulps)
I like when the tea gets cold by the end.
It's that iced tea life is good shit too.
I appreciate all of y'all,
I'll see you tomorrow
at 9:00 a.m. eastern.
I hope this brought value.
My team will now be chopping
up a ton of content,
we'll put it out throughout the day.
I love you.
Dustin, thank you so much.
Let's get quicker on the
ones and twos tomorrow.
- [Dustin] Yes sir.
- And I appreciate all of you.
Have a great, great, great,
great, great, great day.
I promise you,
you will look back at this pandemic,
as long as you don't lose a loved one,
as a good thing.
It is a reset.
It is one step back, two steps forward.
You will find better jobs.
You will start better businesses.
You'll learn how to save.
You'll learn how to be
grateful for simplicity.
I love you all very much.
We'll see you soon.
(air whooshing)
(vibrant electronic music)
(beeping)
(air whooshing)
- What's up everybody.
My name's Jason.
I'm the editor of "WeeklyVee."
In this next scene coming up,
it's a Zoom call the team does with Gary.
We do some Q&A,
and have a little discussion
on how we're gonna position
"WeeklyVee" this week,
that you're watching right now.
So here it is, check it out.
And if you have any feedback,
leave some comments, anything,
that we can make this show better.
(air whooshing)
So, we're doing this, Gary,
'cause I sent you a text that was like,
"Hey, we wanna do 'WeeklyVee.'"
Or more of a question towards you,
do you wanna do "WeeklyVee"
with the teatime,
plus you recording selfie videos?
And you were like, "Hey, let's do this."
So we have a ton of
questions to record content--
- Let's go.
Let's go.
- First question is,
"WeeklyVee" is gonna be
teatime, plus these sessions,
are you cool with that?
- Yes, that was what we were.
To your point, I figured that,
to not just have the same visual.
Let's have some Q&A to fill out like this.
- And are you cool with this
rolling out next Friday,
or do you wanna just speed up the process?
'Cause usually we do
"WeeklyVee" in the week prior,
but this is more--
- I'm okay with next week.
I'm okay with it next week.
- Cool, all right.
I'll do the first question,
and then we'll kind of bounce around.
Leveraging social media in these times
for my small business.
It's a very ambiguous question,
but what do you think just from that,
leveraging of social media in these times
for my small business?
- I think that's all that Q&A was,
so I don't think that's
gonna add to the vlog,
if this is strictly
being done for the vlog--
- On the vlog.
- I think it needs to bring
different value for the vlog,
so I'm not gonna answer that,
'cause it is, to your point,
pretty (switch clicks) what have you.
And by the way.
If this is a complete clunker,
tonight could be a good one.
Like I'm not stressed here, so.
- Totally.
I mean, there's so many questions here.
- By the way, I think
that clip right there
is probably what we should
put in the fucking vlog.
- There you go.
- Me punching you directly in the throat.
(laughs)
(crowd cheering)
Love it!
- Let's do--
- Ha ha.
- Yeah, go ahead, Jake (laughs).
- "Any advice for people
"who are losing their jobs right now,
"and they need to stay afloat,
"or need some kind of other
source of income for this time?"
- Yeah, I mean, I think,
as I talked about on today's livestream,
two things that stand out is selling shit,
and then going into donation world.
I got really excited.
I hope we clipped the
thing where I talked about,
"Hey, why don't you perform,
"if you're a singer, a dancer, a comedian,
"and tag your Venmo thing for donations."
I have a funny feeling
that could be a monster,
so my two things are
really a telethon, or QVC.
Literally, be Jerry at
QVC, or Jerry Lewis.
That is the two things.
There's three things.
You can ask a thousand people
if they have a job for you.
When your back is in the corner,
there's kind of two ways to go about it,
offense and defense.
Defense is,
literally text the (speech
drowned out by feedback),
and on LinkedIn,
"Do you have a job for me?
"This is what I do."
That's defense.
Offense, to me, comes in two forms.
QVC, as you saw today,
and for a lot of people,
a lot of people have a lot of shit.
Even people that are not making
a lot of money have amassed,
this is America, it's a
materialistic society.
We just have a lot of shit.
So, a, QVC, a.k.a.,
selling on eBay, Mercari,
Facebook Marketplace.
Or b, telethon.
Go live on Instagram,
pin your Venmo,
and fucking dance (hands clap)
and hope people give you
some money, like a PBS.
(gentle music)
- Cool.
- Okay.
Hey Gary, this one's from Instagram.
"What are you doing personally
"to keep your energy
up during this crisis?"
- Two things.
One, I'm doing virtual
workouts with Mike Visconti,
so last two days I've
put in some real work,
and working on this,
so I'm excited about that.
A little exercise, physical energy,
and then I spend my life,
15 to 18 hours a day,
in parallel to whatever
the fuck I'm doing,
even while I'm doing this,
I'm in mental perspective land.
Gratitude, gratitude, gratitude.
I continue to expose
the energy to everybody
that outside of a family,
that has an individual that
has passed away from this,
this has the potential to be
a remarkable opportunity for
a reset towards happiness.
I understand people may lose jobs.
I understand people may lose money,
but I think if you really play with this
and put into perspective, and
gratitude, and opportunity,
you will realize
that this can also
become a time of a reset,
that leads you towards a life of happiness
instead of unhappiness
with financial success.
And I believe happiness
with financial okayness
is dramatically more exciting
than unhappiness with financial success.
(gentle music)
- Great.
- I just thought of a question for you.
- Thank you Dustin.
- Since we're doing this,
and it's "low quality,"
I know you've brought it up before,
like during the actual live stream,
and now we're kinda
like resorting to this.
Just wanna talk about that,
since like,
we're going from a really
high production "WeeklyVee"
now to like resorting to this,
and just the fact that it's blowing up,
it's starting to get like--
- Because the production value
doesn't mean shit, sometimes.
And I think that's an important
addition to my conversation,
right.
I'm glad that I said "sometimes."
Because, when you're making
"Avatar," and "Star Wars,"
it does matter.
But I think 99% of people
watching this video right now
need to realize, you're
not fucking George Lucas!
And like everybody buying like,
stop being that tennis
player I always make fun of
that bought the fucking Federer
sneakers, the Nadal racket,
and the John McEnroe fucking headband,
and you spend $8,000 on equipment,
but you fucking blow at tennis,
you lost 6-0 to a guy
with a wooden racket.
That's how I think about production.
I don't fucking need
fucking special effects.
I don't need my lighting to be proper.
You and I, Dustin, were
talking about this earlier.
Like, if we use this clip,
your fucking lighting looks like shit,
you're behind a fucking window right now.
I don't know why mine looks
good behind a window right now,
I think you might have fixed the camera
when you did the hook and thing,
but here's the punchline.
It's the words out of my mouth,
not the fucking camera quality.
"Good news GaryVee, I bought
the Sony fucking 694,"
I'm like, "I don't give a fuck!
"It's still not gonna make
you interesting, dick!"
That's why, Dustin.
It's not the fucking production value,
it's the fucking value
out of your fucking mouth.
It's the value out of the pictures.
When you're in the information business,
it's the information.
Will the production add to it?
Yes.
Do we do better if this
has a good thumbnail
and a good title?
Yes.
By the way, on the record,
I currently do not like
our thumbnails, currently.
I understand that we're
talking to a YouTube rep
and they're probably "more on."
I dunno, I don't see us
doing so remarkably well
that I think about our best practice.
But that's what's cool about it.
That's my subjectiveness.
Jim, Jake, Jason, AK, you,
might like it, might not like it.
It's all fun, that's what I like about it.
But like, maybe I'll start
in like how fat I look
in the last photo,
'cause that could be a new thing,
but like nonetheless,
what I'm saying is,
production, images,
a lot of those things are
gonna be so subjective,
and people spend all their time on it.
Even the words in your
mouth are subjective.
To me, spending 90% of your energy
on your opinion on how
good the quality is,
is what fucks people up.
(laughs)
- Gary, what was the impetus
of reserving the time to go
live five days a week this week?
- Two things.
One, value for audience
and value for myself.
As you know, Andy,
more than anybody in the world,
maybe, besides maybe D Rock,
I've been wanting to do "Tea With GaryVee"
for fucking seven years,
four years, two years.
Like I've been on this kick
of doing a morning show
where I drink tea,
and fucking answer questions,
and so I've always wanted to do this.
And then number two, I have the time.
And number three, I knew
that I was gonna bring value.
I'll be honest with you,
I've been surprised how good.
You know, I'm not rushed.
That two hours, today.
Like you guys have seen it.
You guys know more than anybody, right.
I'm even looking at your head nods,
you guys know the version of
me doing this show right now,
I mean, Jim, thank you for the compliment,
sending me such a nice text,
like I'm really, I'm really
hitting a tone right now.
- I agree.
- I thought I would
bring out good content,
and I thought it would bring value,
and reading my Twitter stream,
and reading my DMs and e-mails,
I've helped some people already.
- Yeah.
There's this really good clip
that we brought up in our 4:30
content meeting yesterday,
that I pitched as a creation,
which was you ranting about
doing it for the user.
Everyone comes up with ideas
about trying to sell products and stuff,
but it's self-interested,
and it just seems really relevant
to what you're doing right now,
you're still doing it for the user.
- Always, though.
This is what we do better
than anybody in the world.
I gotta go to my next meeting,
'cause I'm still operating.
By the way, vlog, I'm
operating my business.
Like I've been 12 hours a day on calls.
I've been operating like a motherfucker,
so I gotta bounce outta here.
I hope you're enjoying the vlog,
here's some more clips,
and I'll keep doing this,
and team, thank you for being on,
I'll talk to you later.
(air whooshing)
- So, how are we doing "Tea With GaryVee"?
I'm gonna show you right now.
As you can tell,
I'm wearing my very nice clothes.
But, lemme show you.
We're gonna go quick, step by step.
Basic idea, basic gist,
of how this is done.
And this took me a lot of different tries,
a lot of Googling,
a lot of YouTubeing.
But you're about to see.
Okay.
So basically, three different softwares
that you mainly need just for this part.
One, Loopback Audio, that's for audio.
Zoom, 'cause that's how we get the video
and the meeting going.
And OBS, which is a broadcasting software.
So, how we do it.
First I create a new meeting,
and just get joined with computer audio.
That's me, hello.
I send this over here.
Unfortunately,
I don't have someone to test
this meeting with right now,
so, you just get the basic idea,
of like, this is where Gary
will pop up, right here.
Pop.
Gary will pop up right
here, on this screen,
my second monitor.
And then, you invite people
one by one into the meeting.
See how I'm the only one here right now.
And then, Gary talks to them.
This is basically then fed into,
come on, where's my
bar, okay, there we go.
This is then linked into OBS,
and that's me right there,
see how you could see it.
So none of this stuff displays,
because the way I have this set up,
so, see, now you don't see it anymore.
Then we have OBS to be keyed
and linked to Restream,
which is this.
I'm not sure if we should
be showing this, Jason,
but you might wanna blur
this out, just in case.
So then, anyway,
OBS goes to Restream,
and that is how it's done,
but as far as,
I think this is the part
where everyone really doesn't
really know what's going on,
is the Zoom part,
and it's actually really simple.
It's just as simple as,
I'm the host of this meeting,
but I turn my video off,
making Gary the host, essentially,
even though I'm the Zoom host,
but Gary is the host,
and then we just have guests
come on one at a time.
And then I set that up that they can see,
so then we have the guests come in here,
one at a time,
and I just ask them to join the meeting
by asking them to enable their video.
That's pretty much the idea.
I'm gonna make a full video about this
because a lot of people have
been asking how it's done,
step-by-step,
so then you'll see that
soon, probably on LinkedIn.
Share it.
Okay, bye.
(air whooshing)
- So we're just gonna go one by one,
ask some questions,
and that'll be some "WeeklyVee" content.
- Let's do it.
- All right, cool.
Well, apparently, five years ago,
somebody asked you this question,
it was, "What was your spirit animal?"
And you said, "Ram-Man from He-Man."
I'm gonna ask it again.
Has anything changed?
What would you say is your spirit animal
at this moment?
- What is my spirit animal?
Probably, are koala bears aggressive?
(laughs)
What is seemingly cute,
and fuzzy, and soft,
but also has like?
Well actually, you know, it's funny,
that's how I see myself,
but I don't think a lot of
people who view my content,
it's almost like, people
that view my content,
actually view it as like
harder on the inside,
but you guys know it's soft on the inside,
you know it's kind of
like a Tootsie Roll Pop.
You know what, the Tootsie Roll Pop owl.
(laughs)
- That makes sense.
- That was my spirit animal.
- Last question from me.
If you could switch roles
with anyone on our team,
who would it be and why?
- Oh, great question.
Who would I switch roles
with on the team, and why?
I would probably switch roles with,
it's a really good question.
(laughs)
I would probably switch roles with Zain,
because I,
and I'm not even sure he's
really, actually doing this,
but what he was hired
to do, or theoretically,
and I know it evolves,
is, I love community management.
Like, if I could,
and by the way,
to remind everybody
who's watching this vlog,
the way I became "GaryVee,"
was replying to every
single tweet on Twitter.
For real.
Eight, nine hours a day, for four years.
Like, people don't get it.
Like people don't get it.
You guys, as a team, know how I work.
So you're like, "Maybe."
No, the answer's for real.
Like if I could reply to
every single 2129315731,
and every comment on Instagram right now,
and TikTok,
and Twitter,
that would make me so happy if
that was 15 hours of my day.
And so, I would say, Zain, in theory,
'cause he's supposed to be
doing community management,
but I'm not sure if he is.
- That's awesome.
That's not who I expected.
I was thinking D Rock,
for some reason, but--
- D Rock would be the last person.
(laughs)
I don't love to film other people,
and I don't love being overrated.
(laughs)
Just kidding D Rock,
I really didn't mean it.
(laughs)
- All right, that's it from me.
Next up, who's on the list?
Who's up?
Is it Dustin?
- It's Dustin.
- Or Dustin.
- Cool.
Are you personally being more careful
with social distancing right now?
- Yeah, I've been quarantined
for a fucking month.
- You haven't been out at all?
- No.
- Oh.
I'm guilty, I've left (laughs).
- Yeah, I'm like,
you know what, honestly,
I wanna see my parents during this time,
like I've signed up for
four to eight weeks,
and so I'd rather not
go out and see anybody
so I can see my folks,
if I wanna go visit
them and go that route,
so that's been the main reason.
- Gotcha.
You say you always love being
around people, and noise,
and chaos,
so what's the past two weeks been like?
- Shockingly good,
because as you guys know,
if you look at my calendar,
I've been busy as fuck.
Like I've been going
hard for 11, 12 hours.
I'm getting so much fucking done,
I'm considering doing
a VaynerMedia Operation Stay
At Home Day once a week,
forever,
'cause I'm pretty sold that
I've gotten more done per day
than sometimes in a month.
This has been a huge eye-opener for me.
I thought this was gonna be the worst.
I'm spending more time with you guys
in this 10-minute Zoom call,
like seeing Avatar's room
like that excites me.
I'm like,
I'm enjoying it, being super productive.
I've been on phone calls, and
Zooms, and Google Hangouts,
for 12 hours a day
straight with no breaks,
so I'm fucking feeling great.
(gentle music)
(laughs)
- That's all the questions I have.
- Thank you.
- I got next.
G, in the famous USC speech,
your first opener was,
"I don't think
entrepreneurship is teachable."
And that's been like a
motto for a lot of people.
Do you think the same
way about leadership?
Do you think leadership
is not as teachable as
entrepreneurship is?
- The answer is yes to both,
but then let's talk about this.
Let's actually separate them.
Entrepreneurship requires
a minimum level of ability
to actually be successful,
no different than being an athlete,
or being a musician,
like not everybody actually is good enough
to actually be a professional musician,
and a professional athlete,
and no level of teaching
courses, watching videos,
and practice, can get you there.
I actually believe that to be
true about entrepreneurship.
You can watch all my videos all day long,
you can learn, what have you,
you can go to business school,
but if it's not your natural talent,
there is a potential,
there's a likelihood,
that you're not able to
build a sustainable life,
happy and successful.
Where there's a little hedge there is,
I actually counter myself,
because I think making 87,000 a year
having a peanut butter startup,
is brilliant.
But for most people,
that would be deemed as
not successful enough
for entrepreneurship.
So, it's a funny way for me to answer it.
I think entrepreneurship is a talent.
I think leadership is a talent.
And like any other talent in the world,
you can get better at it.
I could be a better skier than I am today,
'cause I don't practice,
and I don't watch videos,
and I don't follow skiers.
Can I be better?
Yes.
I think the problem with entrepreneurship
is that people think they're
going to the Olympics
every time they start a business.
So we need more realism.
Leadership,
similar, though different.
You know, it's interesting.
Do I think all of you are better leaders,
because you rub elbows with me?
Yes.
Do I think all of you
are better entrepreneurs
'cause you rub elbows with me?
No.
So I think it's different.
Actually, very fun to tie
these things together.
A lot of you nodded your heads
when I talked about
how soft I actually am,
versus the hyper nature, competitive,
kind of, like standup
comedian I am in my content.
You all responded pretty well
as I was looking at your videos.
I'm a likable, good leader.
I'm showing it in this crisis,
I'm showing it other times.
I think you guys are
better now because of that,
that you'll take that as parents,
as leaders, in the future.
You've learned things
from me, I can see it.
I can see it in Andy,
I can see it in D Rock,
I can see it in Danyah,
and I can see it in Dustin.
I could see it already.
I don't think that means
that you're gonna be,
and I do think that's different
than entrepreneurship,
but I think you've been around me,
and I don't think you guys have
become better entrepreneurs,
per se.
Maybe there's some things
that you know to look out for,
or maybe there's some more self-awareness,
but not better,
whereas I do think you're better leaders,
so I do think leadership is more teachable
than successful
entrepreneurial operations.
- Well, so, with a 1000-person company,
that basically went remote immediately,
what are some surprising things
about building that
infrastructure that you noticed.
What's on your mind with that?
Is it working well, not working well--
- Actually that's going the other way.
The reason it's going so well
is the least surprising
thing to me of all time,
because when you actually
build culture, and a family,
and people give a fuck about each other,
this is when it shows.
What an opportunity in my vlog
to give an enormous shout out
to the Marc Yudkins of the world,
the Claudes, the Alans,
the Marcus, and the Lisas,
the Nicks, the Gs, the Avery, it's like,
the leadership of VaynerX,
James, and Jeff Nicholson, Leighton,
Ryan Harwood, Mary Kate,
the leadership, Ann Kovich, leadership,
at VaynerX, and a few underneath them,
Lisa Hebs of the world,
like Lynda Hs,
like the leadership, Sarah Baumann,
on, and on, and on.
The leadership of this
company absorb this challenge,
remarkably well.
Wanda, and Sarah Murphy,
we're fucking crushing it.
Now, we're a modern company
that's built on the cloud,
so all our infrastructure,
technology-wise, is easy, right?
We give a fuck about each other,
so people are being empathetic and kind,
and worrying about,
while I'm sitting and
worrying about making payroll
and fixing everything
for all the lost revenue,
and all the clients we're losing,
and some real stuff,
my team is worried about
people sending e-mails, saying,
"They feel burnt-out
because they're getting too many e-mails."
And I'm like,
"Motherfucker, I'm saving your jobs,
"that you're fucking complaining about."
But everybody plays their role, right.
And, what's been the biggest surprise?
The lack of surprise.
The biggest surprise is an anti-surprise.
I fucking knew it.
When you actually build a
family and you build culture,
you're ready for the war.
It's a fucking war, and
we're fucking standing up.
(calming music)
- Do you think that companies
that started out remote
can do that?
Do you think the reason
that Vayner did that
is 'cause it was--
- I think they could.
You know, I mean, I wanna
sit on top of you guys.
If I could squeeze all of
you into my office, I would.
So I like that shit.
But I will say this.
I feel super cozy on
Zooms and Google Hangouts
with clients I've never met before.
So I never underestimate technology.
But I do love interpersonal.
I think they're both amazing.
And I do think a lot of companies
are gonna be more remote,
and do more remote stuff.
I'll tell you one thing for sure,
there's a lot of times when
I want to do a meeting,
and I have to wait till
I fly to Cincinnati,
that now I tell my admins,
"Put it on Zoom, put
it on Google Hangouts."
But I'm definitely starting
to build the cadence
of feeling comfortable
in this environment,
getting my cadence down.
You guys know me, I pick up on everything.
So I like being in a
room and seeing stuff,
like I don't even like
that there's some people on this call,
like I don't see Dany and Sherelle
on the screen at the top now,
and I don't fucking like it,
'cause I need to see all of you,
what are you doing,
and what are you doing?
You know, like, because the
way my screen is up top,
all of us are missing two
of the people at the top,
with the way the Zoom goes.
Or maybe, actually--
- If you hit Gallery View
you can see all of us--
- Oh wait a minute,
now I've got it.
- Yeah, on the upper right--
- Let's fucking go!
(laughs)
Holy shit, this is way better.
This is a big breakthrough for me.
Let's go, fucking Zoom.
I'm fucking pumped right now.
(laughs)
This is huge.
I may never go into the office again.
This is a monster moment.
(laughs)
Honestly, I'm not kidding.
Seeing Sherelle laughing right now,
and seeing the thing behind Dany's back,
I need context, which
is why I like in-person,
but technology is getting better,
to where I'm getting the
context a little bit more,
like I'm pumped.
I'm devastated for every
single life lost of corona,
but I don't give a fuck about the money,
and I think we come out stronger,
and I think I come out stronger,
and Vayner comes out stronger,
and a lot of people are
gonna come out stronger,
more self-aware, and try new things.
It's fucking amazing.
(gentle music)
- Cool, awesome.
- Awesome.
- My next thing--
- Look, look, I apologize, Danyah.
I would argue right now that
I even just brainstormed,
do I want Team Gary to do a
one day a week work from home,
but they have to be on
Zoom the whole time,
in the background of what they're working,
and will that actually make
us even more of a team,
not less?
And of course, people put music in,
and mute people out,
of course, like if I was part of it,
I'd be annoying the whole time,
I get it,
but I'm innovating.
This is the time to innovate,
and I'm excited about it.
Danyah, take over.
- All right.
I think that's a great idea.
Bringing kind of a different perspective.
So, someone that has a small nest-egg,
I know you're always
talking about saving money,
and setting stuff aside,
and--
- Amazing how cool that
just got, all of a sudden!
When everybody else was talking about,
"No, don't save money,
and put it all into play,
"and" (gurgles),
and, "You only live once,"
and, "Put it all into the
market, and leverage,"
and all of a sudden, everybody loved that,
and I was like the boring, like,
"It's gonna take 22
years, and save money,"
and at least I was charismatic
in a different way,
so it made me, but like
let's not get it twisted,
plenty of people hated
the shit I was saying.
It's amazing how in a
week, everyone's like,
"Wait a minute."
- Yeah.
So, the person that has
listened to your advice,
and has like a chunk of money,
maybe $5, $10,000,
what do they do with it now?
Just sit on it?
Do they invest it--
- Stocks are under-priced.
Stocks are under-priced.
In 18 months
they're gonna be better
than they are right now.
Go buy fucking Amazon.
Go buy Netflix.
Go buy Facebook.
Every secondary market.
Like, sports cards are
still gonna be explosive
in the summer and the winter,
and guess what, prices are down.
Like I can't wait.
I'm so busy right now,
but I can't wait to maybe late next week,
like maybe, not this weekend
but the next weekend,
when it finally settles in a little bit,
to spend eight or 10 hours
to just buy a ton of shit,
'cause things are down.
Everything's gonna be fucking down.
If you have money right now,
you've got leverage.
But right at this minute,
for this vlog, when it airs.
By the way, you know how I
said we can wait a week, Jason,
for this vlog to come out?
I would argue that we need it to be
as time-sensitive as possible,
so if it comes out on Tuesday,
I know we were going
for that Friday thing,
but let's say the right thing
is for this to come out on Monday,
then I'm cool with that, just FYI--
- All right.
- Instead of waiting.
'Cause I just thought,
if this thing was pitched
Friday, fuck, man,
the way the world's moving so quickly,
like shit could change, so, anyway.
So Danyah,
I think that coming out of this,
I could see real estate,
I can see other things,
going down in pricing.
There's a lot about to happen,
but right this second,
I mean, I dunno, what did
the stock market do today?
Say yesterday it went up like crazy.
Today, it is, up 500 points.
Yeah, stock, I just think stock.
I think stock is definitely under priced,
compared to where it's going to be,
if you have 5 to 10,000 bucks,
and you're okay with
looking at what it's worth
in 24 months.
I definitely think flipping stuff,
I think premium sneakers,
premium cards,
cards, they're down.
Those two stand out.
And then, 5 to 10,000,
yeah, I mean look,
this is how crazy this is,
there's gonna be some businesses
you can buy for 10,000 bucks,
that were making 100,000 in profit,
but their owner was selling
T-shirts on Instagram,
and she or he was spending 120,000,
and now they be thinking, get the fuck,
they need 20,000 real quick,
to just like get out of their situation,
and you can buy their
business for 20,000 bucks.
- Yeah.
Okay, I have a special guest,
she is super excited to be on.
My mom is watching this with me--
- Let's go.
- Can she ask you a question?
- (laughs) She can.
- Okay.
- Hi Gary.
Hi.
- How are you?
- I'm fine.
I'm Amy, Danyah's mom, and--
- Amy, it's such a pleasure to meet you.
- It's nice to meet you too,
because I've been hearing
about you for years,
and it's exciting to see her
actually make this happen,
and be out there,
and I appreciate your mentorship.
So, my question for you is,
with you talking about organizations
being able to convert working from home.
I'm a retention executive at Dish Network,
and within 24 hours,
our call center sanitized everything
and sent equipment home with people
that have never worked from home.
Turned it around.
And we are so productive right now,
it's amazing to see what's happened.
(dog yowls)
Do you ever get into businesses like that,
and actually spend the time on the ground
looking at other organizations
and what's happening,
for instance, some
place like Dish Network?
Which I'd love to invite
you to come to our site,
if you're in Phoenix.
- Thank you.
So, first of all, listen,
first of all, Amy,
just by the relation, we're family now,
so the answer is,
I'm telling Danyah right
now to listen to this,
she needs to talk to my admins,
and if I'm in Phoenix for
some reason, I will be there.
I will make an addition to any trip,
and I will find a reason to be in Phoenix,
sooner than later.
As far as do I?
I am a learner through osmosis.
It's less likely for me to
go see how Disney does it,
or Netflix does it,
or Dish does it.
Now two good things.
One, this chapter of my career
was to service big companies,
so, by nature, I've walked
into Chase, and Diageo,
and Budweiser, and Google,
and have seen what you're talking about,
so, one of the great reasons
I wanted to do VaynerMedia,
was I knew that it was going to,
I was going to get paid
to walk into businesses,
and because I'm a
multi-dimensional thinker,
I could do my job while,
in the corner of my eye,
watch how they do that,
or how they did the reception,
or how they do these things.
So, through the osmosis
of what I do for a living,
it naturally happened.
- Yes, so, Gary, of all the things
that has happened since corona struck,
what has made you the happiest?
What like little, tiny thing?
If it's like working outside
of work hours, or something.
- I played a shit-load of
football with my little guy,
and so, those are moments
I wouldn't have had,
if corona didn't hit.
So that is number one, in real life.
In macro GaryVee talk,
people have learned so
much about themselves
in the last eight days.
Every single person, I think, on earth,
has actually created a new
insight about themselves,
that they did not know
had this not happened.
By the way, for some
people that's a bad thing.
Not a bad thing, let me phrase.
For some people,
that's gonna be a step backwards,
for two steps forwards,
whether they've realized something.
For many others, it's gonna be a positive.
I will tell you that I never
thought working from home
was in my cards, ever,
till the day I died.
I now know it is.
That's exciting.
That means 52-year-old Gary
can take an entire summer off
and be on the beach, and
be productive as fuck.
That's kinda cool.
I don't know if I will like that.
But you know, it's like,
my favorite little
thing is very big thing,
'cause that's how I roll.
People are just going to be able
to learn about themselves
more because of this,
and I think a stunning amount
of good comes out of this.
I really do.
If you look at it in 20 years from now.
I believe that.
I really believe it.
- Okay,
so Team Gary has made a
lotta content over the years.
I know you don't
necessarily watch all of it,
but what's your favorite piece
of content that was made?
- That's a great question.
My favorite content by far,
is the content that has my family in it.
Like, I thought about that photo,
you guys know that photo
where I kiss my dad
hard on the side of his
face in the parking lot,
that was what came first to mind.
The fact that there's a
video version of that moment,
I'm pumped.
I'm really pumped, like
emotionally pumped about that.
So, probably that.
One of the other things,
just to give you full transparency,
the blueberry piece of content,
was a big one
because I think that got
like three million views
or something like that on Instagram,
so it did remarkably,
all-time well at the time,
but it was also one of the earliest pieces
of me doing something outside of me,
and just showing human me,
so that was a fun observation.
I love that piece of content.
God, there's a lot, boy.
I'm really grateful, you know, it's funny,
my answer about my dad,
is a micro answer to the macro.
Guys, do you know how
much better my documentary
is gonna be in 37 years
than everybody else's,
because there's gonna be
unlimited content to pick from?
So, this!
This is fucking cool.
I just need you, this is important,
I want the seven of
you to understand this.
You will watch this
exact video, in 49 years.
(gentle music)
Your great-niece is gonna
communicate with you
with whatever the text
thing of the day is,
and then it's gonna say,
"You worked for GaryVee?
"That's cool."
So, all of it, my dad
kiss photo and video,
definitely, definitely, the
blueberry thing stands out.
The rant in the white T-shirt,
for doing, for the diploma stuff.
The, "You could have been a fucking bus."
The one where I like get
into that conversation
with that woman about cursing.
(speech distorted by mike cutting out)
the worst performing for all this,
'cause we need that humility,
so that feels good.
Just all of it fucking feels good.
This is the best part.
This is why I feel like
I'm the ultimate creator,
it's all good.
Fuck the analytics, fuck the numbers,
all of it's part of the
fucking entire work of art.
It's like children.
Every one of these pieces of
content like fucking sure,
I fucking love them all.
When they underperform,
when they over perform.
The Jets sweater video,
the Larry King interview.
There's a lotta shit.
There's like highlights on the high,
but on the low, I mean it.
The post I did two or three days ago,
where we didn't title it,
it was the TikTok that I
just posted as an Instagram,
that I just felt like I had to do it
and it was the right message,
but sure enough, it underperformed,
'cause it wasn't contextually
post for use for Instagram,
and I was like,
"Good, Gary, take that
fucking L you fucker,
you think you know.
"You think it's just
message, not production?
"Well here, right in
your fucking face, dick."
You know I like that game with myself.
- Cool.
- Awesome.
- I love you guys,
- Bye.
(air whooshing)
(beeping)
(wind blowing)
- [Gary] Hello.
- Hey G, what's up?
- What up.
- Same thing as last time.
We're gonna do some Q&A.
- Let's go fast.
- All right.
We're starting with May, here we go.
- Cool.
- G, you often say,
positivity and optimism.
For you, what's the
difference between the two?
- Caleb, can you go mute
when you're not being,
'cause you're making a noise
with the walking through.
- You look amazing, by the way.
I love it.
But just go on mute while we go,
'cause I got cut off.
Go ahead May.
- Yeah.
So you always say,
positivity and optimism,
but what do you think is the
difference between the two?
Is it just like popular the other day?
- Positivity and optimism.
To be honest with you May,
and this is what's fun about this vlog.
First of all, hey everybody
who's watching the vlog.
We tried to mix in some of this
to make this week's
"WeeklyVee" more interesting,
so thanks for joining us.
You just saw Caleb is doing
some crazy shit, Jesus Christ.
Anyway, this is fun, actually.
I have not given enough thought
on how I think about the difference
between positivity and optimism.
And I'm not quite sure how I
think about them differently.
Optimism to me is like
hope, like I see it,
like I think it can.
And positivity is like,
be happy, or like do good.
So there is something there,
but I'm gonna spend some
more time on that, May,
and I'll get back to you.
- Thank you.
- So Gary, tomorrow's Sell Stuff Saturday.
People wanna know,
what are you gonna be
posting tomorrow to sell?
- I'm gonna probably be,
I, unlike a lot of people,
do not have cashflow issues,
because I've been saving money,
so I am not feeling as
desperate to sell something.
However, to build up hype
tomorrow heavily for it, I will.
I went to my parents' house,
that's where I am now,
to get out of the city,
so I'll probably find some old stuff
that I had in my house, to sell,
my parents have plenty of my old stuff.
I'll probably, mainly be
promoting WineText, and wine,
because my dad always feels really happy
when I'm building up his business for him
when I'm around him.
So we'll figure some shit out,
but I'm really excited about it.
If you're watching this
on Friday or Saturday,
today, or tomorrow, is
Sell Stuff Saturday,
something I came up with
the "Tea and GaryVee" logo
would probably be (speech
distorted by poor connection).
Oh, actually right, you're
not hearing this today,
I apologize.
So Sell Stuff Saturday
has already happened,
when you've seen this weekly vlog.
Jason, are we gonna do
Tuesday or Wednesday, Jason?
- Tuesday or Wednesday.
- Awesome.
So this last Saturday
was Sell Stuff Saturday.
Here's some highlights
of what people sold.
- Hey everyone, my name is Zain,
I'm a proud community/channel
manager for Team Gary.
This past Saturday we
did something really cool
called Sell Stuff Saturday.
How this all came about was last week
there was a "Tea With GaryVee" episode
where Gary and a really cool caller
talked about he could
increase his spending
by just selling stuff around his home
that he doesn't need any more.
Things like clothes, and bike,
and just other common household items.
And so this past Saturday
we created a challenge/event
called Sell Stuff Saturday,
and people from all
around the world came out
and just sold stuff around their homes
to increase their savings.
And we saw a lot of cool things from it,
people made 50, 60, $100,
just selling clothes
from around their home.
We saw one person, I think
he bought a video game,
an N64 classic video game, for 75 bucks,
sold it for 600, which is insane.
And one gentleman, I
think he even made $2300,
just selling things from his house.
And so, if you wanna go
see what it's all about,
if you wanna get motivated,
check out #SellStuffSaturday on Twitter
to see what it's all about.
And if you wanna flip
and get into the game,
please tag Team GaryVee on Twitter,
we wanna follow along and
see how it went for ya.
See ya.
- Gary, so I always ask
you this kind of stuff,
on a personal level, when we hang out,
but on a holistic view,
what do you think are gonna
be the cultural impacts
after COVID's passed?
What do you think's gonna stick?
- Remoteness.
I mean, I'm the most anti-remote person.
Right now I work from home,
'cause I (speech distorted
by connection issues).
I'm already, just five days in,
feeling very close to you guys right now,
the intimacy of, like,
obviously I know your kitchen, Justin,
but like Caleb in his spot.
Remoteness will stick.
Some percentage of remoteness.
Like I'm even debating doing
one day a month from home,
just doing Zoom meetings operationally,
'cause I've been very effective.
In the office, like I see you.
I dunno, it's been very good.
So, remoteness.
I think delivery.
What's up, Sis?
- Hey.
It's Gary.
- Hey, "WeeklyVee,"
it's my sister, Liz Novello.
She is a real estate agent.
If you're buying homes
in New York, New Jersey,
you need to get route one.
Dayna, let's do a little pop-up
with her handle right here.
All right, get outta here Liz.
- Part of this team.
(laughs)
- No you're out, you're out.
- Aw.
- So, I think remoteness will stick.
I think, delivery.
I think a lot of people have
bought tomatoes, crayons,
for the first time.
Obviously a lot of
people use Amazon Prime,
but I think a lot of people are spending,
by the way,
we're gonna be here
for another three, four, five, six, weeks.
I think people are gonna get used
to buying things on the Internet,
that they used to go to the store to,
and realize they like that,
so I think direct to
consumer is gonna stick.
Buying on the Internet is gonna stick.
Remoteness is gonna stick.
I think people are gonna
figure out their relationships,
these confined homes with friends
and family, mainly family.
I think some relationships
are gonna break up,
and that's gonna stick.
I think some relationships
are gonna get better,
and that's gonna stick.
I think some new hobbies are gonna happen,
I think people are gonna
pick up a thing or two,
that's gonna stick.
I think perspective is gonna stick,
I think a lot of people
are gonna be grateful
for their relationships, their
friends, their loved ones,
when they finally get to hug.
Like I'm gonna hug the
shit outta each one of you
when I see you.
And I barely see you guys,
which is the weirdest thing, right?
But there's something about it.
So, a lotta shit's gonna stick, brother.
- G, for a lot of businesses
that we speak with these days,
everyone's really doing a good job
of running their business and
making millions of dollars,
over the last few years,
and stuff like that,
but they've not really been
focusing a lot on social,
so how can they use this
time to learn about it,
and what would you do if
you were an entrepreneur
that was running a successful business,
but didn't have any social media?
What would be the first few
things that you would do?
- Sid, it's really funny,
you know this about me.
My advice is no different
than a really good health
and wellness person's.
Exercise and eat well.
I'm not gonna change anything.
I know that almost 90% of
people watching this right now
knew what the answer was gonna be.
It's just doing.
This is about doing.
And educating yourself.
What would I do, in a more tangible sense?
I would go on YouTube and Google search,
I would go very, very literal.
How do lawyers make money on Instagram?
And I would read 20 things.
How do I get clients for my
real estate investment firm
through social media?
Enter.
I would spend 20 hours
of deep consumption,
because, if they're consuming news,
they're getting the
philosophical strategy.
The way I give tactical strategy
is through our decks that we put out,
put up a link right now, of
the motto and the company,
and through yelling at people,
"Watch what I do, not what I say."
Right, that's my way to be tactical,
is watch what I do, not what I say,
and occasionally come out with a deck
that's super fucking detailed.
But there's a lot of people
who like whiteboards,
and like charts, and shit like that,
and that's how they teach.
And I would consume that,
and then build up the courage to me.
But this is a mental fuck in here.
"I'm a lawyer, I can't
be silly on TikTok."
You can.
"I don't know how to dance on TikTok."
That's everybody's fucking excuse.
I don't know how to dance on it either,
who the fuck,
watch what I do, I don't fucking dance.
(tranquil music)
Who's next?
- Sinander.
- I'm going on last because
I asked the last one.
- Cool, Caleb.
- Right, I'll go.
Gary, one of the Chinese
hashtags on TikTok is,
"The more you know,"
so just like a quick fun fact
that you feel like would be
relevant in a time like this.
- The more you know yourself,
the more happy you will be.
Self-awareness is one of the
greatest gifts of all time.
Don't be embarrassed with who you are.
Love what you are, and lean into it.
Period, end of story.
You're not detail-oriented?
Who gives a shit?
You're awesome.
You're not creative?
Who gives a shit?
You're not like, fucking,
the more you know yourself,
and I watch people try to
disguise what they suck at, right.
Instead of leaning into
what they're great at,
and I wanna fuck that.
- Thank you.
- Hey Gary, big fan.
(laughs)
Funny bro.
So I know you do the 180
strategy, and I love it.
Is there anything else that
we should be doing right now,
besides just having patience
and putting in the work
on Instagram to grow it?
- To grow Instagram?
Collaborations, live.
I like collaborations like
going on somebody's page
who's smaller than you,
analyzing them,
and then DMing them and saying,
"Hey, let's do a collab,"
because you know what really
(speech distorted by connection).
Everybody wants to go to
somebody who's bigger than them.
Like everybody wants to go to somebody,
like people who have 400
followers DMing me, be like,
"GaryVee, we should do a collaboration."
And like, cool, I'm funny, I
have the humility to do that,
but they're not giving
me any other reason than
it would help them,
and I'm all about charity,
me and Lou have been sending
masks all over the place,
left and right.
I'm quiet about my charity,
but I love charity,
but don't come at me with like,
that's just a weak come.
Like go analyze somebody, and be like,
"Hey, let's do a live together."
Right.
"I'll go live and I'll bring you in,
"and we'll both be live,
"like let's do a live together,
"and like shoot the shit.
"I'm a baker, you're a cookie maker,
"let's talk."
"I'm a florist,
"you're a landscaper, let's
do something together."
Like, go find somebody smaller
than you, and do a collab.
You cross-pollinate two people
with 80 people following them,
give each other 20 followers
from a collab live.
Now you're 80 to 100.
I love the game of building.
So, that's one.
Becoming more educated, like,
are you doing polls and stickers
on your Instagram Stories?
If you're not doing Stories, perfect,
main feed perfect,
and Instagram Live perfect,
you're not doing Instagram perfect,
or you're not doing it well.
And so like, a,
realizing there's three
factors in Instagram,
and make sure you're
focusing on all three.
A lot of people just
one-dimensionally have it,
only do the main feed,
or they only have the
main feed and one Live
once in a blue moon recording.
Or they do Stories because it's stackable,
but they don't push in the main feed,
but when they do Stories,
they haven't learned all the filters,
or the overlaid stickers.
The sticker culture of
Instagram Stories is amazing.
We kinda suck at it,
that's another thing I wanna talk about,
there's so much uptake for polls,
and questions, and quizzes.
Like we need to get way more creative,
as a matter of fact, fuck,
I just got motivated.
Let's get 30 minutes on
just Instagram stickers,
next week, the whole team,
we're gonna just jam,
I'm gonna give you guys all I got,
'cause we suck at it,
we need to get better at it.
So anyway, get better,
that's what I think.
- Thank you.
(upbeat music)
- Katee you're up.
- Hello.
- Hello Katee.
- So a lot of influencers
I've been seeing,
are talking about,
they're worried because campaigns
aren't going on right now,
so their main source of
income is in a hard place.
What is the biggest marketing opportunity
for them right now,
that you would give them?
- To build up their audience for leverage
for 100 days from today,
and bring value,
so instead of getting selfish
and trying to get money
out of their audience,
bring better content than ever,
and, I hope to God that they've
been saving their money.
Unfortunately, a lot of influencers
that have been making money,
have been buying their Yeezys,
have been taking their spa days.
My number one hope from this,
is that people learn how to fucking save.
What are you gonna do?
Like what's my tip?
What do you mean, what's my tip?
My tip is, you should've
been fucking listening,
because right now, people
are scared to spend money.
- Yep.
- What, are you gonna beg?
What, are you gonna lower your rates?
Like, what?
There's consequences.
And the consequence of
you not listening to me,
and buying dumb shit,
and over-extending yourself,
and now having nothing to fall back on,
is you're gonna be in trouble.
Your fucking BMW is gonna be
repossessed, motherfucker.
- Thank you.
- You're welcome.
- That's everyone, G.
If you could wrap up the vlog,
this'll be the last scene of it.
Just, everyone's going into the weekend,
of this quarantine week two,
just give some--
- And hopefully everybody's watching this
on Tuesday, Wednesday, and after, so,
whenever you're watching this,
we're probably two, three
weeks into this shit,
we probably got two to 10
more weeks of this shit.
We've probably got another
year of it being a cloud,
'cause is it going to come
back in the fall and winter?
Whatever plays out, just keep
your shit in perspective.
If you are fortunate enough
to be watching this right now,
and not being somebody
who's lost a loved one
because of this,
or who doesn't have
somebody on a ventilator,
no matter how much business you lost,
back to Katee's question
about being an influencer,
your restaurant being closed,
money doesn't mean shit,
when somebody you love the
most in the world dies.
And so this is perspective time.
Be grateful for what you have,
don't cry about what's changed.
It's devastating for seniors
that miss out on their
prom and graduation,
I understand that's your world,
but I promise you,
to thank God that everybody
in your family is okay.
Focus on the good,
focus on the gratitude,
because if you watch the news all day,
if you go on social all day,
you're getting into fear,
everything's fucked,
da, da, da, da, da,
blah, blah, blah.
Get your fucking mind right.
Make sure corona got your mind right.
(air whooshing)
(whimsical music)
(beeping)
Okay, Gary at VaynerMedia,
say you're Eddie with
the weird background,
bridge in the background (laughs).
- Yeah, I'm driving, so I don't wanna--
- I love it bro.
Don't fucking drive and fucking talk,
you better pull over,
I'm actually letting you go,
Gary at VaynerMedia, we'll talk soon.
- I think--
- I don't think we filled them in
that it was being a Zoom call,
is my assumption.
- 'Cause Jason
fucked that up.
Who's fucking fault is that?
All right, let's not
waste time, let's move on.
- I'll take blame.
- Morning everybody, teatime.
It is teatime.
I think we should have a teatime song.
♪ Teatime at Vee time ♪
Anyway.
I apologize, I was unfortunately
not paying attention.
One more time, my friend.
(laughs)
- No, no, man, you're good, you're good.
- Like with a 1000-person company
that basically went remote--
- Before we go any further, right,
this orange, it's not a pink, like.
- It's not my house, but
it got built somehow,
so I'm in this room and it's fully orange.
(laughs)
- I love it bro.
I also like the sweater, love the couch.
Dude, I feel like it's--
- I've fully downgraded my--
- Dude, it's 1978.
- No, this is how I am at home (laughs).
- I love it bro.
I love you, go.
- When the people gonna
see you dance on TikTok,
'cause I'm waiting,
I'm sure there's other people waiting.
You and me, we gotta do the
Renegade or something, or.
(laughs)
And on that note.
- I feel you.
If I'm a 9 out of 10,
or a 9.5 outta 10,
if I can really rock
for another 40 years of 10
out of 10 in entrepreneurship,
I am a 1.7 to a 2.6 in dancing.
I can do the Crab.
I feel good about the
breakdance move the Crab.
- She never even heard.
- You know what, I'm gonna
do the Crab tomorrow,
and try to start that as a trend,
and someone on my team,
can you guys find me a song
that will go well with the Crab,
I don't know if there's a Crab song,
but I think I'm just gonna go
fucking go for it tomorrow,
so the answer to your question
is tomorrow, Sherelle.
From my other tea map,
I'm gonna literally film
myself doing the Crab,
and try to get that to be
the viral hit on TikTok.
And by the way,
if God forbid it goes viral,
the fact that we'll be
able to clip this moment,
to that, to that,
that's gonna be another
viral post on Instagram,
so we got big stakes,
and the answer to your
question is tomorrow.
- Is cheesecake a cake, or a pie?
- Cheesecake is a pie.
- That's controversial.
- Is it?
I really think, when I think cheesecake,
it feels more pie-y to me than cake-y.
- Yup, cool.
- I'm more commonsense.
I'm sure somebody's gonna
reply in the YouTube comments
of like, "Technically, the,"
I'm like, "I don't give a fuck dude."
Like, it feels pie-y.
I can understand, technically,
the milk or the this,
I'm sure there's some reason
to define cake and pie.
I will say that I am
disproportionately more pie over cake.
- Do you like cheesecake?
- I do like cheesecake, actually.
I love ricotta cheesecake.
That shit is fucking gnarly.
But all of you made these weird faces,
so now I'm like, is that the fucking,
do they serve that at the
fancy restaurants that I go to,
am I bougie now?
- I never heard of it.
- Yeah, I crack off a little bougie.
That's kind of like--
- It's old-school Italian.
- You know what's funny?
One of my favorite ice creams
is virgin olive oil and basil,
like basil and oil ice cream.
And then everybody always makes faces,
I'm like, oh they serve those
at the bougie fucking
places that I like to go to.
And my bougieness comes
from the wine business,
like all those years being
in the wine business,
all the events, all the meetings,
were always in the top restaurants,
so I don't even eat in those
kind of places no more.
(hip-hop music)